what I want to do in this video is
familiarize ourselves with one of the
most important molecules in biology and
that is glucose sometimes referred to as
dextrose and the term dextrose comes
from the fact that the form of glucose
typically four typically found in nature
if you form a solution of it it's going
to polarize light to the right and
Dextre means right but the more typical
term glucose this literally means sweet
in Greek if you ask a Greek friend to
say sweet it sounds like Lucas or I'm
not seeing it perfectly but it sounds a
lot like a glucose and that's because
that's where the word comes from and it
is super important because it is it is
it is how energy is stored and
transferred in biological systems in
fact right now when if someone were to
talk about your blood your blood sugar
they're talking about the glucose
content so when people talk about blood
blood sugar they're talking about your
they're talking about your glucose
content the whole process of
photosynthesis this is all about plants
using harnessing the sun's energy and
storing that energy in the form of
glucose when we talk about when we talk
about things like respiration in our in
our cells cellular respiration that's
all about taking glucose and using it to
full and to create ATP's which are the
molecular currency of energy inside of
our body so these are in credit is an
incredibly important molecule we can
start wreaking chains of glucose to form
glycogen to form starches this along
with another similar another simple
sugar fructose you can use to form our
table sugar but even glucose by itself
is sweet so let's get familiar with it
as a molecule so immediately when you
look at this is it kind of drawn as a as
an open chain we see that we have one
two three actually let me number these
we have one two three four five six
carbons so chemical formula would be C
sub six a subscript of six we have how
many hydrogen's how many hydrogen's we
have we have 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12
hydrogen's c6 h-12
and then we have how many oxygens do we
have
have one two three four five six oxygens
six oxygens so you might notice we have
six carbons and then the ratio for every
one oxygen we have two hydrogen's which
is really the ratio of hydrogen's to
oxygens in water and if we want to
really if we really want to if we add
obviously here we don't have just two
hydrogen's and one oxygen we have 12
hydrogen's and six oxygens but it's
really good to even just familiarize
yourselves with what are the different
parts here so we see on the number one
carbon it is part of a carbonyl group
when a carbon is bonded to double bonded
to an oxygen like that that's a carbonyl
carbon eel carbonyl group and in fact
because this carbon it's double bonded
to an oxygen but then it's other bonds
are - I guess you could say a carbon
chain right over here and then but this
other bond right here is a hydrogen we
would call this an aldehyde we would
call this an aldehyde group and it makes
al dehyde and it would officially make
the entire molecule an aldehyde if you
contain an aldehyde group you are an
aldehyde so glucose and when it's
written when it's drawn as a straight
chain or it's a straight chain form it
would be considered an aldehyde and then
of course it has all these hydroxyl
groups on them and these hydroxyl groups
these Oh H groups over here that would
officially make glucose also it would
officially make it an alcohol and it's
neat to keep in mind how the structure
is so you have six carbons one of them
is part of this aldehyde group it's part
of this carbonyl right over here and
then the other five are each bonded to a
hydroxyl and what I've oriented it this
way four of the hydroxyls are on the
right-hand side and the one on the three
carbon is on the left-hand side and all
of the other carbon bonds are with
hydrogen carbon likes to form four
covalent bonds every one of these six
carbons has formed four covalent bonds
and so you would fill up all the rest
once you've accounted for this carbonyl
here and you've accounted for all of
these hydroxyls everything else is going
to be hydrogen now this is when you've
drawn when you've drawn glucose just as
a straight chain but many times you will
see it in its cyclical form it's neat to
kind of think of
how do you go from this form to this
form over here and so what I've drawn
here is this exact same this exact open
chain but I've started to I've started
to bend it a little bit and just to be
able to keep track of things let's
renumber
the carbons so this is the carbon that's
part of the carbonyl group
so it's carbon one and then we number up
from there two three four five and then
that is the number six carbon the reason
why I've made these this bond over here
nice and fat is to show that it's it's
kind of closer to us it's popping out of
the page and as we go from the the
second carbon of the first carbon we're
going back into the page when we go from
the third carbon to the fourth carbon we
are going we are going back into the
page right over here so this big fat
bond this is between carbon three and
carbon two that's this that's this right
over here and this going from two to one
that's this bond and I'll draw it a
little bit kind of going in and then
this bond is this bond right over here
and so it take a second pause the video
if you need but try to orient yourself
to orient yourself imagine we're going
to take this to the right like this to
bring it over here and then we're going
to rotate we're going to rotate this end
and Bend it up backwards like that to
get to this form C six is now bent all
the way up is now rotated all the way up
there we've bent we've bent this chain
and the whole reason is is because this
will typically react the hydroxyl group
this is it this is the the most typical
form of glucose you will see when you
see in a sick little form there's
actually other forms that you can have
but the oxygen that forms a hydroxyl
group on the fifth carbon it can it can
attack it can attack the the the number
one carbon that forms this carbonyl
group and that's because oxygen we've
talked a lot about it is very
electronegative likes to hog electrons
so this carbon is partially positive and
so you could take one of the lone pairs
you could take one of this oxygen right
over here it's going to have two lone
pairs let me just draw them as neatly as
I can that's one lone pair and then this
is another lone pair right over here so
this oxygen can form a bond with this
carbon when we learn organic chemistry
and more depth we'd call that a
nucleophilic attack it sounds very fancy
just the fact that these are drawn to
each other this has a partially positive
charge this guy has a lone pairs of
electrons that can be used to form bonds
with things and so when that when those
electrons form this bond or bond to this
carbon that's going to be this bond this
bond right over here and then this
carbon can let go this carbon can let go
of the electrons in one of these let me
do this in a more obvious color and in
the double bond right over here it could
let go of one of the bonds the electrons
in one of the bonds and then that can be
taken back by the oxygen or even better
that can be used by that oxygen to
capture a hydrogen proton in the
solution and actually probably part of a
hydronium molecule but let me just draw
it this way this would just be used to
capture a hydrogen proton that would
just be a hydrogen a hydrogen atom
without its electron it's just a
hydrogen ion it would just be a hydrogen
proton and that would form this bond
that would form this bond right over
here and let me let me just be very
clear this carbon this carbon right over
here is this carbon right over there
this oxygen this oxygen is this oxygen
is that oxygen right over there and so
hopefully you see how it forms a cyclone
you're promising oh wait wait don't we
have a little hydrogen attached here
isn't the way I've drawn it looks like
there's an extra hydrogen over here and
then that would leave this guy with a
positive charge we leave with a positive
charge but you can imagine we're in a
solution of water then hey I have some I
have another water molecule right over
here and you know these things are all
bouncing around and interacting in
different ways but it could use let me
do that in the right color it could use
so that's oxygen it could use one of its
lone pairs instead of this you know this
will become positive temporarily but
then it can use it can do it can use one
of its lone pairs to grab just the
hydrogen proton which would allow which
will allow this character to take its to
take its electrons to take these
electrons back and turn into this
character and just be neutral and then
this this guy would have gained so we
have a proton going into the solution
you have hi
but we took a proton from the solution
we took a proton we gave a proton to the
solution and so you could end up with
this so the whole reason I did this is
just so when you see it in biology class
or chemistry class you're not
intimidated by it in fact this is
something that's really valuable to get
very very familiar with because you're
going to see glucose and other sugars in
many many many different molecules
throughout your academic career